i'm sure you are all very familiar at
this point with herschel walker who is
running for senate in
georgia against raphael warnock and
recently there was a sort of scandal
where he made a remark
about how this is the context this isn't
the scandal but he made a remark about
how
a problem in the black community is
fathers aren't staying with their kids
and they absolutely absolutely need to
do that and it's a really big problem
and i mean we can have a discussion of
course we want to encourage people to
stay with their kids absolutely that's
not not really what this is about
it's more a hypocrisy angle and so just
to refresh your memory let's look at a
couple of those moments
the fatherless home is a major major
problem even if you have to leave that
woman even if you have to leave that
woman you don't leave the child right
right you let that child know you try to
work it out you're going to be
respectful to her if you're going to be
respectable to other things you show
that to your child marshall walker who
was born in wrightsville georgia you
know i took it i took care of a lot of
people in my hometown i took care of a
lot of the places around where i grew up
i was being like a father to some of
those kids that it may have had five so
generally i have no problem as i said
with people encouraging you know men to
stay in their families and all those
things of course that's absolutely what
fathers should do but one of the ways
the republicans
specifically get out of
answering for any real policy
prescriptions they have for the country
in regard to these really big problems
sometimes that are more specific to
certain communities
is by making it an individual issue and
so instead of proposing large actions
that the government could take or
actions that we should as a political
body uh invest in time or energy
money
instead
it's all about that guy that one and
that one and that one that one it's just
they made bad decisions which on an
individual basis if that person was my
friend yeah i'd give them that advice
hey stay with your kids right
but on a societal basis these big
problems that he's trying to address
in answering whatever question he was
answering is something we have to
address on a societal basis basis big
trends
big issues that we see broadly
in our country aren't going to be be
solved by someone just saying a bunch of
rhetoric and people are gonna hear stay
with your kids and now all of a sudden
all these problems are gonna be solved
no if you see broad
societal problems we're gonna have to
have broad societal solutions and those
have to be policies
that we can implement
using our political power and so
republicans do a really good job of
getting out of answering for hey what's
some policies that you that you would
propose to invest in these communities
uplift them instead they make it
it's just
some bad dudes that's the core of all
these problems but you and i understand
uh specifically since he was referring
to them the black community
the way that we solve any problems that
we recognize are
unique to that community is not just by
finger wagging right again you have a
friend you want to give them that advice
awesome or even you want to encourage
society broadly stay with your kids love
your kids of course you should do that
but that's not the solution to all these
problems we have that we need
to
[Music]
uh we need to address
and to put a cherry on top of all of it
herschel walker's son
is very outspoken he's a conservative
and he put out a video supporting his
dad's message that was a little bit
cringey
fathers it would be great if you stayed
home and raised your kids instead of ran
off to bang a bunch of women who weren't
your baby mama stay home and raise your
freaking kids your kids need a father
get back home get back home if you take
out your thing and you get a woman
pregnant guess what the party days are
over the acting foolish days are over
you go get a freaking job and you
support your new
family get home
raise your so
very
in your face so that's kind of all the
context to the story that we're talking
about today
that would mean a lot maybe more at
least coming from someone who's living
the principles that they're espousing
who is loving and supporting their kids
all of their kids
but after these statements made by
hershel walker it came out that he had
three children with three separate women
who were not previously disclosed to the
public which for someone as famous as
him to have kept them unknown for that
long
that's not an accident and there is no
way he was active in their lives in the
way that he's saying other people should
be
or there would be some public record of
that some
public record for someone as famous as
him
so
you would think that would upset that
type of hypocrisy that type of not
living your family values would upset
evangelical people right that's what
they they claim to care about
uh no
i'm sure you'll guess that
herschel walker received resounding
applause from evangelical christian
activists on saturday following
revelations he had fathered three
children he had not previously discussed
publicly the half full room of
conference goers at the faith and
freedom coalition's annual gathering in
nashville went wild for walker perhaps
the most high-profile republican senate
candidate this cycle running in one of
the most contested
races
even though it is really clear by now
that republicans don't really care about
having politicians who
live the principles they claim to hold
it still fascinates me every single time
when this you know plain examples of
hypocrisy come out and they don't care
at all a very clear example of this is
trump evangelical evangelical
republicans claimed to care about family
values and that's what justified them
being super judgmental towards all of
these groups who didn't live the way
that they wanted them to live
i.e the lgbtq community but then trump
comes along
has a very anti-evangelical past if you
want to say it that way and
they don't care at all it's wild
and i think this is honestly one of the
reasons
that they are still as successful as
they are because they'll take anybody as
long as you'll
say their talking points spread their
message act the way that they want you
to act you're in
it's not about consistency it's not
authenticity it's power if you can take
power and use it towards their ends the
ends they actually care about
then
you're a part of the club and the funny
thing is comparing that to the left is
pitiful because the left if you step on
a bug
you're out so we could take a little bit
of a lesson from them and be a little
bit more tolerant of people with
not perfect pasts but generally i like
where we stand i'll be following
herschel walker's
race with raphael warnock that has been
very fascinating so far but i'll be
watching it each step of the way and
covering it on my own show you can find
that at luke beasley on youtube or if
you're listening to this as a podcast
you can search luke easley on any
podcast listening platform to listen to
it we'll be back with much more
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today is helix sleep i sleep on
a helix mattress at home i absolutely
love it and that's why i reached out to
them about sponsoring the david pakman
show
buying a mattress in the past
was always a huge guessing game for me i
didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like but helix
has a sleep quiz on their website you
tell them your body type your sleeping
position your back pain issues you might
have and their tool matched me with a
mattress that is perfect for me it's
cool enough at night it's the right
firmness i generally just do way better
sleeping these days because of the
mattress helix was awarded number one
best overall mattress for the last two
years by both gq and wired magazine it
is well deserved i can tell you
firsthand every helix mattress comes
with a 10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights and they will even come pick
it up at your house if you don't love it
but i know you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
slash
helixsleep.com
it's the biggest discount they've ever
offered the link is down below